oui tu là
à douala allez les coûts sont en avance
quand tu manges un rêve d'y piocher au
monde partir alors un petit jus et
vitamines des beignets allez-y sa tête
des mauvais jours
qu'est-ce qui se passe le déménagement
est bien là en garde de bien montrer
raymond tout près du centre-ville en
cinq minutes on va aller faire du
shopping l'organe entre filles
c'est pas ça le collège jallet
d'inscrire la dernière fois j'ai trouvé
clause était déjà super beau en cas d un
parc avec des arbres en braille et
ombragé on a accueilli les bras ouverts
il se décompose pour toi ce que tu fais
du matin et on a de moins en moins en
plus d'être super hot
donc tout va bien il va ton but et qui
font des affaires
[Musique]
deschamps
vraiment quel quartier ici by cc le
quartier des deux canons à bompas qui
parient les patries simple quoi tu sais
les réputations il faut toujours se
méfier
et où du camp nou quoique sofina au
gapeau coûtera vs d'or
[Applaudissements]
ensemble
oui bonjour ma fille ça rigole on va
prendre une école à l'est
quoi tu me bouscule regarde d'où tu
marches
[Applaudissements]
pourquoi tu me bouscule ça va tu étais
pas réveiller ou quoi bon je vais te
faire visiter le collège quoi je parle
quoi ça va pas
[Musique]
en
la séance de travail à faire à son issue
d'une filiation ont progressé
non
[Musique]
pour y arriver donc on va vous demander
vos tribulations que jusqu'au bien sûr
[Musique]
non
mou
[Musique]
vous
non
[Musique]
mais
on
ça
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
mais
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
le champ
[Musique]
m
j
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
les zombies
[Musique]